morning Leslie do you have a good night
I did I watched a really good document
what is that this is what I did last
night
after I got home I drank six more
glasses of whiskey and then I finished
crafting this small harp using a bandsaw
a spokeshave and an oscillating spindle
sander
[Music]
beautiful but wait there's more here are
some photographs of me drinking the
whiskey you'll notice I'm holding up
yesterday's newspaper so you can tell
that I'm not lying I feel like I'm in a
spa I like saying no it lowers their
enthusiasm it's actually not that
serious I just need you to stay calm
okay
yeah I'm just gonna stay angry I find
that relaxes me everything okay
nope my boyfriend is a lawyer and he's
smart and interesting and there's a lot
of things about him I like but he acted
like a real jerk today I don't know
there's something about the way he
treats people or something he's a
tourist the vacations and people's lives
takes pictures put some in a scrapbook
and moves on all he's interested in her
stories huh
basically Leslie he's selfish and you're
not that's why you don't like him on my
deathbed my final wish is to have my
ex-wives rushed to my side so I can use
my dying breath to tell them both to go
to hell one last time would I get
married again oh absolutely
if you don't believe in love what's the
point of living drippers do nothing for
me I like a strong salt of the earth
self-possessed woman at the top of her
field your Steffi Graf's your sheryl
swoopes 'as but I will take a free
breakfast buffet anytime anyplace
Ron will show you around right this way
is the exit hey Mark
welcome to my Haven thank you you were
the first non me to set foot in this
building in ten years
Ron none of this is up to code sure it
is it's up to the Swanson code there's
no drainage doesn't seem to be any
ventilation you've got Hauser's
chemicals over here yeah which only I am
breathing the same liberty that gives me
the right to fart my own car are you
gonna tell a man that he can't fart in
his own car there is a basket of oil
soaked rags above a wood-burning stove
good thing I've got a fire extinguisher
which I can assure you it's totally up
to your precious code it says it should
be recharged June of 1996 those dates
are arbitrary they're like those
expiration dates that the government
forces companies to put on yogurt
medicine observe watch yourself
yeah okay I'll replace this happy any
luck
no didn't work out as well as I thought
it would no better luck next time I
tried just didn't see well I love that
hat thank you ma'am I'm hungry okay well
don't be such a baby I cooked you some
bacon for a trail snack I hate it
already I could smell it in your purse
before I even parked my car and now it's
gone and I hate everything Thank You
Darla why would anybody ever eat
anything besides breakfast food
people are idiots largely right yeah Ron
wake up Ron wake up its Leslie Oh God
you having a bad dream
no I suffer from a disorder called sleep
fighting must be terrible only when I'm
losing I'll get what I need from the
spreadsheets Thanks
what's a not-gay way to ask him to go
camping with me
Ron hello Andy
it's quiet in here where is everyone the
government is shut down it's in every
newspaper
how long is gonna last no four lucky
this building will be empty for months
okay so sorry new ringtone don't cut
anything without me
Leslie you will grow from boys into men
from men into gladiators and from
gladiators into Swanson's behold the
Swanson pyramid of greatness I've been
developing the Swanson pyramid of
greatness for years it's a perfectly
calibrated recipe for maximum personal
achievement categories include
capitalism God's Way of determining who
is smart and who is poor crying
acceptable at funerals and the Grand
Canyon rage poise property rights fish
for sport only not for meat fish meat is
practically a vegetable haircuts there
are three acceptable haircuts high and
tight crew cut buzz cut are the scissors
broken in your house son the less I know
about other people's affairs the happier
I am I'm not interested in caring about
people I once worked with a guy for
three years and never learned his name
best friend I ever had we still never
talk sometimes Andy this was delicious
it's awesome it's a whole new meat
delivery system thank you so we say we
go out to the parking lot run a few pass
plays to burn off the calories you are
an unstoppable good idea machine
libertarianism is all about individual
liberty and it should never be defined
by the terms liberal or conservative and
communism is no good that's right big
swinging a Miss yeah and what's the word
for when a few clerics are in charge
religious oligarchy holy I can remember
things I guess hmm I keep my rare a man
after my own heart
suppose you'd want to move to Canada no
I don't suppose I would
hello Ron it's Ron if you're watching
this it means that once again you have
danced with the devil
right now you're probably thinking
Tammy's changed will be happy together
but you're only thinking that because
she's a monstrous parasite who entered
through your privates and launched
herself in your brain so you have two
choices one get rid of Tammy or two
lobotomy and castration choose wisely
stupid do you fish April no sheesh up
close let me give you a piece of fishing
advice I said I don't when you have a
fish on the line
you don't just drag it behind the boat
you either reel it in or you cut him
loose especially if he's a nice fish
with a big lovable fish heart you don't
know what you're talking about
maybe not maybe you really do hey Tandy
maybe moving to indianapolis just to get
revenge on him is a really good idea
what do I know I couldn't care less
about the commendation but Indianapolis
is home to Charles Mulligan's Steakhouse
the best damn Steakhouse in the damn
State I have taken a picture of every
steak I've ever eaten there June 2004
porterhouse medium-rare Bearnaise sauce
January 2000 they call this one the
enforcer February 96 a steak ribeye the
whiskey Lagavulin 16 the lady next to me
a [ __ ] specifically my ex-wife Tammy
okay this is this is the first time I
ever went there oh just a kid call me
let me know where you are anything from
what in the devil's name is this
portobello mushrooms where's the steak
oh there's no steak
that's a healthier option it's
organically grown
okay okay can you get us a cold
conference or something come on
everybody let's hustle let's get to the
brainstorming great attitude Ron I just
want to get the work over as soon as
possible so I can do some fishing
fishing relaxes me it's like yoga except
I still get to kill something
I don't like dentists just a second oh
[Applause]
I'm sorry everybody what were we talking
about recycling dentist pulled the tooth
out yesterday but it's always a good
idea to demonstrate to your co-workers
that you are capable of withstanding a
tremendous amount of pain plus is always
fun to see some of the faint
you